Oh River babes I'm glad you're here
I'm your host Liana Galera and I'd like
to welcome you to our Sweetwater secrets
preview for episode three 2255 prom
night yes I am all decked out in my
little problem homage I hope you like it
now I don't know about you but my prom
night sucked and I honestly can't
remember my dates name so fingers
crossed our characters will have a more
memorable evening
now before we watch our favorite weird
aliens dance the night away I'll be
teasing you with what you expect with my
three clues
plus I have an exclusive new interview
with Charles Melton's filling what's
next for Reggie and giving me an update
on his off-screen relationship with
Camilla Mendes and it's too darn cute to
miss and as always I will be taking your
live Q&A comments you guys are already
flooding it right now I see you Abigail
su jazzy Jones hi Kate Dunbar but first
let's take a look at your kisses kisses
comments and theories from episode 319
chapter 54 fear the reaper I think it
was 55 I think that's my mistake now
kicking us off Serena dgo Oh Serena
DiGiovanni wrote kisses - both Fred and
Josie for being amazing characters we'll
miss them both on Riverdale I couldn't
agree more Serena meanwhile it seems
like all of you River babes were
freaking out just as much as I was over
that hilariously bizarre farm family
reveal now trisha jaha posted I knew
something was wrong between Evelyn and
Edgar
mm-hm and Tesla Kanta was equally
creeped out writing simultaneous hisses
and kisses to the fact that this episode
managed to make me reach a new level of
discomfort there and then the chosen
Malfoy seemed to really appreciate my
delivery of what the farm is going on
here because they said loved that line
why thank you now keeping it moving heta
Escom voiced her opinion and said kisses
to Gladys telling sp the truth and then
leaving I never needed her to be the big
bad it's just a hi room for being Hiram
B
again I never needed him to be the big
bad hopefully we can get through these
last few episodes with just the gargoyle
king and the farm oh well I hate to
burst your bubble babe
but Hyrum has a big role in the finale
and yes it'll make your eyes roll and as
for the big twists that they were quote
no survivors during an inmate transfer
accident well a lot of you have some
really great house centric theories now
Cory MCD added hisses to Hyrum for
probably having for probably having
killed Hal Cooper you didn't have to do
that and they also added kisses - sweet
sweet Betty I feel bad for her she's
lost her all her family now and I don't
know how she hasn't cracked yeah can
someone please get Betty like a gift
certificate for a spa day home girl
needs a relaxing vacation except asoto
sheesh next up Millie's Davidson is
weighing in and saying theory house
staged his death so he could escape
prison and kill Edgar and Evelyn for
Betty
I like that theory but ELISA D is coming
in with her own ideas and wrote the farm
definitely killed how just saying well
you know what I've been dying to know
what you all have been saying and
thinking about how about Houdini Hal's
disappearing tricked so I've resurrected
our pole in e t--'s community tab now I
asked if you all really think that how
Cooper died in that car crash and more
than 10,000 of you voted now 7% of you
said yes I think Hal is finally gone for
good
32% answered no way Hal is alive and
faked his death and a whopping 61
percent voted for to be honest I don't
care anymore that's fair neither do i
but i do care about the fact that we
only have three more episodes left in
Riverdale's third season so let's take a
look at what we can expect from episode
320
thinking about tomorrow I'm thinking
about the rest of your life
you met the gargoyle King I have nothing
to hide
let's end this nightmare are you
well that promo pretty much told us
nothing so let's see if I can shed some
more light on what you can expect from
chapter 55 prom night with my three
clues number one
Edgar's manipulative ways could be
proving to be a bit too frustrating for
one for me
number two they say prom is a night
you'll never forget but I bet this gal
wishes she could and number three one
character and maybe m.i.a from prom
night but don't worry I caught up with
him to find out some answers now take a
look at what Charles mountain told me
when I chatted with him at the premiere
of KJ oppas new Netflix movie the last
summer how much of a proud bro are you
right now of KJ I'm a proud big brother
young right now how you gonna support
him and everything yes have you seen the
movie yet I haven't seen it yet I'm
excited to see it we haven't talked
about it yeah keeping the mystery alive
how are you gonna be spending your
summer Thank You spending some time with
a sweetheart named Cammy yeah I'll be
seeing her we'll be hanging out going on
movie dates how are things going with
you guys I'm so excited for you good
we need specifics I've seen this week's
episode of Riverdale I want to know
where's Reggie he's taking care of
business you'll see him soon it was Luke
Perry's last episode recently how do you
feel like his legacy is gonna live on in
the show Luke Perry's a great man he is
and his legacy is gonna live forever
everyone he met he affected in a
positive way I appreciate it I do I'm so
excited for the Sun is also a star it's
already getting so much why a buzz
what's one thing you learned about yara
while you were filming that you didn't
know about her beforehand oh she doesn't
like to share desserts unless it's with
me don't worry we've got it
we're gonna see you in this super-sweet
rom-com and I'm curious enough it's not
a rom-com a romance oh I love that yeah
you know like there's comedy aspects to
it but some more of the romance in it my
best friend came to support and I'm
going to his premiere so next week gonna
be changing for mirrors I love that
matching is possible too yeah anyway
what are you guys talking about I love
those bromance vibes and I love Charles
and cami together and for all you river
babes who are wondering you can watch
KJ's movie the last summer this Friday
May 3rd on Netflix in Charles's film the
Sun is also a star hits theaters on May
17th now let's do our live Q&A sessions
because you guys have been flooding my
comments first alright let's take it
back to the beginning Kate Dunbar says I
was really hoping how could have been an
Inside Man for Betty to help take down
Hiram I doubt he's really dead because
well yeah it's Riverdale what do we say
guys no body no believe in always we
need to see that dead body and even then
they'll probably come back to life
because it's Riverdale yeah I went ok
elegant blogs by Maddy welcome back
girls so glad you're always here every
week said I think that Veronica is going
to find out about Archie nearly shooting
Hyrum instead of protecting him to be
honest I totally forgot about that plot
twist and I feel like everybody else has
too but I like that you're digging deep
let's take it back we have Sidney
O'Connell saying we out here complaining
about who's gonna be prom king slash
Queen and Queen when in reality we'll
only see like five minutes of the actual
prom shake my head I mean maybe more
than five minutes they're not by much
the costumes are interesting they're
very GMG related which I like but I
didn't wear that to my prom this is as
close as I could get on like a last
minute situation do you like it it's
like Renaissance I don't know
okay Jasmine Rickey said my prom also
such Leanne hope our favorite characters
have a great night
yeah there's so much pressure on prom if
any of you river babes are in high
school trust me it's not gonna be the
best night of your life it might be a
really fun night but you'll have plenty
of better nights to come still have fun
though go with your friends don't put
all the pressure on going with a date
never works out quiet storm kisses to
Betty for not letting the farm brainwash
her Josie for her performance Fred for
being himself and Gladys for punching
Curt yeah how did you guys feel about
Gladys leaving I was a little bummed out
because I really loved Gina Gershon
playing that role and you felt like I do
feel like we reached the end of her
character I would like to see her come
back but I'm okay with her going I'm
glad that JB is staying and we're gonna
get another really cute brother-sister
scene between JB and jugg tonight so
that's what I'm here for Lauren with
Abby emoji and a yellow heart emoji said
his sister Alice for still marrying
Edgar when he's already married yeah
what state is revered Ellen are we are
we allowed to have Sister Wives there is
this okay okay um let's see Kiera
Oh Mira said Hyrum definitely killed how
if you did it's five hundred hisses to
him it's a lot of hisses would we really
be upset at hyerim killing Hal though
that might be worth a kiss we always
give hisses to the high room I might be
I might be down with up Phoebe Reed what
if Hal is working with the farm and he
faked his own death to help Edgar make
Betty join the farm
Oh Phoebe I like that theory because
it's unexpected because right now we're
thinking that how doesn't like Edgar
well right now we're thinking House dead
I have no idea poor Betty
poor Betty riverdale found the farm
kidnapped Hal and is going to use him to
show dead people in this case Betty
because they know they can't fool her
ooh that's an interesting twist as well
I'm still personally frustrated that we
still have not gotten to the bottom of
how the farm is showing Cheryl Jason I
would like to see that scene I would
like to know like are they giving her a
good drug to make her go to sleep and
and infusing her dreams like conception
style it sounds crazy but not that crazy
considering what we've seen on this show
who knows okay um
oh they want that phallus and barchi tea
oh gosh don't we all phallus fans I
don't know what to tell you our our ship
our ship has sailed for now and it's
very sad because Alice is so deep into
the farm and so underneath
Edgar's clutches that I'm not quite sure
what's going on there as for barchi tea
mm-hmm well you know what I'll tell you
that if you tune into the Sweetwater
secrets after-show after this episode
you might be having an exclusive new
interview with the lovely KJ Appa
spilling some exclusive archie team and
his thoughts on it so who knows it'll
happen
uniq Karen are unique Karen eek but you
know I know you girl
where is chick I can't believe I'm
saying this but I miss chick and his
sketchy weird vibes I have an amazing
theory about chick that I will be
spilling in the after show and I can't
wait for you guys to hear because I'm
really proud of it and I think it's true
so tune in to the after-show we have so
much to discuss this episode isn't
insane Vista Trista seven said do you
think it was wise for Jughead to stop
GLaDOS from killing penny penny will
just come back to try and kill Jughead
again now um I do not think that it was
unwise for him to stop his mom from
killing penny because now penny OHS drug
had a favor because he actually saved
her life because GLaDOS was gonna kill
her I love penny Peabody I love the fact
that it's kind of like a recurring
villain that comes back over and over
and over again I feel like I'm watching
the flash because she's one of the only
villains that I respect like I'm like I
see you penny Peabody you get knocked
down you get an eye taken out you keep
coming back and we always know she's
gonna be thwarted she's never actually
gonna win but I like your gusto girl
topaz iconic says why is everybody
hoping Hal escaped
sure he'll probably kill Edgar Develin
but murder isn't good under any
circumstance and I'm pretty sure he'll
come after Alice next
yeah I mentioned this in the after show
but at this point there's so much murder
in Riverdale that I just like Oh dead
body oh look another dead body
oh if any way if anything like a coroner
Curtis jr. creep Nick face has like the
most money in Riverdale because he's
just got like bodies and bodies that
he's just looking at being like yep
they're dead I'm still creepy I don't
know you guys losing it we're so close
to the season being done Veronica X
lodge can bar cheap bands be excited for
tonight barchi fans can expect some
scenes together tonight how's that Josie
just left last episode we know our she
moves fast but like let's give him a
minute you already know you already know
it's Kayla
hey Kayla I know that now says everyone
is pushing Betty to join the farm but
I'm hoping she's stronger and smarter
than that to give in honestly at this
point yes I'm so excited for Betty but
the farm is so relentless and her mom is
there and Edgar's there and he's so
attractive that at this point I'm just
like you're dealing with enough stuff in
your life you do you girl no I don't
actually want her to join the farm but
like poor Betty she's had the worst
season she's had to deal with the most
awful things that have been happening to
her I just she needs some lovin she
needs to go back down to the bunker I
don't know Abigail I know you know what
I'm talking about mysterious stranger
says I think Hiram is going to
manipulate Veronica to get to Archie
yeah and I agree with you do you know
why because he's done that like 18 times
already it's always Hiram tries to get
on Veronica's good side and then
Veronica goes oh my god like papi I love
you so much you're so great you're not
such a bad guy and then they get to
Archie and then Veronica's like I can't
believe my dad did that I'm so pissed
and then they concoct a plan and then
like it's all over and over again
Wesley heart said I think chick is
coming back and I need and I need that
let's be honest we all hated him but
loved him I thought he was like creepy
but also sexy in a crew
way I'm not gonna agree with you on this
sexy part and I feel like chick last
year was like Hiram this year where we
just gave him hisses every time because
we're like go away chick but yes now
that he's left I'm like comeback chick
watch next season if they like diminish
Hiram's role be like hi Oh miss Hyrum
the show
why are we so addicted what what does
this pull it has over us celandine so
I'm sorry if I'm saying that name wrong
but I'm glad you're here
says I wish the gladdest revival had
been a bigger Oh had I wish Gladys the
reveal had been a bigger blow would have
loved to have seen more tension I think
it's an opening for Foust what do you
think I feel like things with the Gladys
and FP storyline were just kind of all
over the place I'm glad that it wasn't a
bigger blow up that FP found out about
Gladys and their drug dealing because it
was dragged on for so long if it had
been like as soon as he as soon as jug
had have found out when it was like FPS
birthday party then we could have had of
it like be a more big thing but I'm glad
they just brushed over it because if
they had spent any more time on it I
would have screamed I don't care about
the fizzle rocks I don't care about her
drug trade I don't care that I don't
care right now they want the show neat
e2o Shoni fans Oh show me fans we will
be getting shown in tonight's episode
you will tune into the after-show
because you and I are gonna be on the
same page same exact page when I go into
my hisses and kisses you and I would be
like this got you shown any fans
Starbucks lover says I think Hal might
be jealous and mad that Alice is
marrying Edgar and he's going after the
farm that's fair
jealousy does make men do crazy things
and House already crazy so who knows if
that's the fuel that's sparking his
potential escape or fake covering up
death or maybe he really is dead and
we're actually getting in real death I
have no idea Sidney O'Connell can we
discuss Cheryl's mental health and
Toni's backstory oh and a Kevin
storyline
so in terms of Cheryl's mental health I
do feel like we could touch upon it more
but we did get to see when Cheryl and
Tony were making up that Cheryl was
explaining to her that when she was
growing up she had awful parents she had
a really tumultuous childhood so I feel
like we have touched on that a little
bit yes I would love to see it more but
we have we've gotten to the roots of it
a little bit and I really appreciate
that
heck yes to seeing a tawny backstory I
would love to see what little Tony Cho
house was like at like JB's age that
would be sensational
a flashback could be fun although I'd
love to see Vanessa Morgan play it and
then for Kevin goodness gracious you
guys know I've said this every single
week at this point Kevin is just there
and it makes me sad because he's so
great he's just always there it's like
Where's Waldo where's Kevin there he is
he looks so cute okay you know horsey
girls do you think penny is sisters with
Alice and Penny's child was Betty and
Alice stole Betty
then Alice ordered Edgar to manipulate
out Alice because he is part of the
Ghoulies horsey girls that takes the
cake as the most complicated theory of
the day plausible probably not likely
but I really appreciate all the threads
you were trying to connect there penny
in and Alice I feel like don't look that
similar as maybe it's just the blonde
hair but um I really like how deep
you're going in there I don't think
we'll get that though but job um we're
gonna just take a couple more oh and bug
head fans you guys want the tea - we're
just gonna tweet just have a couple
sessions you just talk about our
favorite couples bug head share scenes
together tonight that's new and there is
a really really sweet interaction
between Betty and Jughead once the
subject of prom comes up and when you
see the scene it's really sweet because
like you're just imagining that that's
how lily and Cole act around each other
for a split second it doesn't feel like
Betty it feels like it's like Lily
talking to Cole and it's really sweet
but once again hugs for Betty poor girl
okay serpent Queen my theory is that
Tony is actually brainwashed
oh no she says my theory is that Tony
isn't actually brainwashed and she wants
the farm to trust her so she collects
information about them so she can expose
them there's no way Tony got into the
farm love makes you do crazy things it
would be great if Tony was being like a
photojournalist and whipping out her
camera and like exposing this story
because clearly Alice is not using her
journalism career because she's just
standing in front of the camera I'm like
looking at it I'm holding it I love I
love news reporter Alice it makes me so
happy because I'm just imagining that
[ __ ] on set just oh she's great but yes
be stronger Tony I know it's hard and I
know that it's you can't control being
brainwashed but I would like to believe
that Tony actually is in control of the
situation - um Caitlin Jones
what if Clifford blossom is The Gargoyle
King no I thought we already did that no
I thought we thought no what if he is
The Gargoyle King Penelope gave him the
poison that they put in the kool-aid and
he ascended and he is the only adult
apart from how that was mentioned in the
flashback he died like twice if they
bring back clip and blossom for a third
time I'm done mate most likely Cheryl
fell down sorry Cheryl
got very heated there for a second two
more they're really trying to figure out
who screamed in the promo you mean you
don't know our River babes screams by
this point you guys hmm no I'm not gonna
tell you that it is very gut wrenching
scream and it goes on for a very long
time for a very very long time it's a
lot those last ten minutes as Roberto
said mmm okay and Dawn of the Dead will
Archie rebuild the red circle who routes
mad dog to take on Hiram was the red
circle this year you guys who's that
really still this year please tell me
that was season two what's the red
circle this year so much has happened
I can't even wow I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep holding here for a second because I
need you guys to answer if that was this
year because if it was that I have
completely forgotten everything that's
happened this season has felt like three
years because of everything that's
happened and yet not much has Wow okay I
feel like I can find a couple more
Cucina Val kova said so after that
answer I'm pretty sure it was Cheryl
screaming in the [ __ ] in the promo what
the farm I hope that what the farm
catches on you know what you guys if you
need like a new PG saying cuz you're it
cuz you're in school or with your
parents just be like what the farm they
have no idea what's going on and it's
really fun to say
okay just a couple more gummy bear pizza
says as much as I hate penny I
understand why she's after the Joneses
jug had cut off her tattoo and Gladys
cut out her freaking eye I'd be pissed
too
yeah Oh penny they're saying mad dog was
last season red see red circle was
season two oh thank god
right there okay alright alright guys
we're so close we're gonna stop there
we're gonna stop there thank you river
babes so much for tuning in to this live
preview for episode 320 and be sure to
check back with me after you've watched
chapter 55 prom night for our Sweetwater
secrets after-show featuring a new
exclusive interview with KJ APPA plus
all those other little nuggets that i
promise that you'll get because it's a
really good after show and I would know
cuz I wrote it
but first you know how this goes give
this video a like hit subscribe so you
never miss any of the Riverdale goodness
and then head on down to the comments to
tell me what you think is gonna happen
on prom night which vixen do you think
deserves to be queen
what the farm is making you most
frustrated and who do you think is
hiding under the gargoyle mask at this
point shout it all out and I'll see you
after the episode bye river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]